Today, we'll be speaking with Josh Dubin,
who is a defense attorney and ambassador,
advisor for the Innocence Project, a criminal
justice reform advocate and also host of the
podcast Wrongful Conviction Junk Science.
Josh, it's so great to have you on today.
Thanks for having me.
Happy to be here.
So just to start with, can you talk a little
bit about how you ended up working in the
area of wrongful conviction and sort of the
path that led you to that?
Sure.
You know, I've always been interested in criminal
justice reform, and I got a call when I was
like in my late 20s, I had this odd path because
I was known as a jury, as a jury expert.
So I would get hired by criminal defense lawyers
to help them pick juries.
And that was the way it started.
In some civil attorneys as well.
So I got a call from Barry Scheck, who I had
known from watching the O.J. Simpson trial
when I was in college.
I actually thought it was my brother pranking
me so I'd never return the call.
And then the person that the person that referred
me called me names, Gerry Lefcourt, who was
a civil rights icon who represented the Panther
21, the Black Black Panthers at that that
their famous trial.
And Abbie Hoffman.
And he called me and said, what's your problem?
I referred you to Barry Scheck and you don't
call him back.
So I called them back and I met Barry and
helped him with a case and it sort of took
off from there.
Shortly thereafter, Barry Scheck and Peter
Neufeld had a civil practice, civil rights
practice, where they were beginning to represent
people that they had helped exonerate through
at the Innocence Project in their civil suits.
And I began working with him and we really
hit it off and it sort of took off from there.
So big, big picture.
You can find all sorts of different reports
that that claim one in 25 people on death
row is innocent or some percentages.
There's all sorts of different numbers that
that are applied, generally speaking, to folks
who have been convicted and are in prison.
What is a good way for the lay person to wrap
their mind around what portion of people convicted
for serious crimes are are are actually innocent
of those crimes?
You know, it's difficult to tell because you
don't know how many people are out there until
you take on their cases.
So I don't put much stock into the statistics,
but I'll give you one that I do put a lot
of stock into.
And this is only dealing with one state.
You know, the state of Florida has 29 exonerations
off of death row.
Twenty nine.
They have only executed ninety nine people
in the state of Florida.
So I'm a shitty math student.
But if you do the quick math that shows you
that a staggering percentage of people that
were sitting on death row awaiting execution
were actually innocent.
I mean, I was the lead attorney for chlamydia,
Gary, who was the twenty ninth exonerated
from death row.
And I'm currently representing James Daley,
who I think should be the 30th exonerated.
He's either going to be the 30th exonerated
or the one hundredth person executed.
So I hope it's the former and not the latter.
And I'm working real hard with my team to
make sure that that isn't the case or that,
you know, that is the case, that he gets exonerated.
But look, it's hard to know what percentage
I would venture to say that it's much higher
than people think.
And it's a scary number because even one innocent
person sitting on death row rows too much.
So in interviews and documentaries I've seen
about the Innocence Project and Barry and
Peter, one of the things that seems very important
in so to set the context.
The Innocence Project gets far more requests
than the number that they can take in terms
of the number of cases that can be handled.
Many of these cases take years to be resolved.
So there's a there's a selection process that
happens there.
And certainly it's important how strongly
correct me if I'm wrong.
You feel that the individual in question is
innocent, but how much of the calculus, again,
given that there are limited resources and
a limited number of cases you can take?
How much of the calculus is about the likelihood
that you could actually get a conviction overturned?
That's a good part of the calculus, you know,
and different criminal justice reform organizations
have different criteria for how they go about
assessing cases and whether or not they'll
take them.
You know, I have a little bit more liberty
because I don't work at the Innocence Project,
although I'm an ambassador for the Innocence
Project.
So sometimes I take on Innocence Project cases
and that they're they're my first love, if
you will.
But, you know, I can say that different people
do this work for different reasons.
Some people take a look at a case and say,
you know what?
There are terrible legal violations here,
constitutional violations, and that if you
know there's something worth fighting for
here, regardless of their assessment of a
person's guilt or innocence.
And for me, that's important.
And it's also important to me, you know, I
think that, look, we're human beings.
I think that the more I feel that someone
is innocent, the harder I think I'll fight,
whether on a conscious or subconscious level.
So I think that.
Likelihood of success is definitely a factor.
But I can tell you that all of these exonerations
are a an arduous battle, a steep uphill climb.
You're fighting against very tall odds.
So I hope that that was a long winded way
of answering your question.
Yeah.
I mean, how much does a gut instinct factor
into your belief about a possible case?
A possible person?
You'll represent a client's guilt or innocence.
How much of it is gut?
And how much of it is reviewing the facts?
I try not to let my God lead me in one direction
or another, and I try to to base it on on
facts or or absence of facts.
And there's a very there's a very particular
reason why I sort of ascribe to that.
And why what is that?
Because it's got it's the gut of detectives
and law enforcement.
Some as some oftentimes well-intentioned but
extraordinarily misguided, that leads to the
wrongful accusation in the first place.
Which leads to the cause.
Confession was relates to making up evidence
to make the the ends justify the means that,
you know, it's a it's a very dangerous path
to go down.
Because I'm often humbled by evidence that
or the lack of evidence that conflicts with
my gut.
So I try not to let my gut get too involved.
And because, again, I think that, you know,
it's oftentimes detectives feel like in their
gut that if a spouse is murdered, it's the
surviving spouse that did it.
And they started focusing on them because
that's their gut.
And it can lead to tunnel vision and confirmation
bias and a whole host of problems that are
a pretty terrifying slippery slope for the
accused.
There are a very long list of of reasons and
different ways in which innocent people can
end up convicted.
And as you're talking about, tunnel vision
from investigators can be a way where where
somebody becomes the suspect relatively early
on at the exclusion of maybe others.
Junk science is another aspect of this.
And for example, forensic dentistry is one
that's been explored significantly and has
been involved in in a lot of retrials or exonerations.
Can you talk a little bit about how would
you sort of categorize the different buckets?
That would be the main ways in which innocent
people end up convicted.
Yeah, no, that's a great question.
You know, one of the things it's also a natural
Segway for me to plug the podcast, but, you
know, on our podcast, Wrongful Conviction
Junk Science, we explore a different discipline
of junk science on every episode.
And it's not something that I'm plucking out
of thin air.
I am doing it.
Law, in large part based on the National Academy
of Sciences report in 2009 that examined these
various disciplines of forensic dentistry
and essentially found that the only one that
that is reputable and has any bankable, reliable
science behind that is DNA.
So we examined everything from bite marks,
as you mentioned, forensic dentistry to arson
to, you know.
Footwear impressions to ballistics, to gunshot
residue, to to fingerprints.
Think about that.
We have always been taught in pop culture
on true crime shows that fingerprints are
the gold standard and they're not.
And if you really examine any of these disciplines
of forensic science, you find out that even
attaching the word forensic to it or calling
it a science is a misnomer because many of
them were born in in basements and at the
hands of some crackpot that did not get even
minimal buy in from the scientific community,
much less apply the scientific method.
And they get accepted in one case.
And because of art, our system of legal precedent,
they all order all of a sudden start spreading
through the justice system.
And, you know, we get these, you know, various
forms of of alleged science that you need
a 40 hour correspondence course to get declared
an expert and then, you know, you end up with
the real problem.
My full conversation with Josh Dubin will
be available on The David Pakman Show YouTube
channel very, very soon at YouTube dot com
slash the David Pakman show.
We will go to
a quick break and be
back
after this.